speeches campaign trucks and photographs
this might look like campaigning there
normal times they are because this is an
election dirty corona virus pandemic
candidates tried to give speeches from
trucks that are socially distant from
voters handshakes are replaced with
gloved fist pumps and thumbs ups
staffers wear face masks that match
their party's colors in late February
South Korea was one of the worst virus
hit countries but two months later and
moved ahead with the national election
meanwhile the pandemic has pushed dozens
of countries to postpone their elections
including some US primaries I'm speaking
to you from my home and forced
candidates to cancel rallies and go
online outside Korea elections are
either being suspended or being
conducted in a very restrictive manner
but hearing Korea there's a dose of
normalcy but with a few adjustments so
here's how I voted in a nationwide
election amid the pandemic
voting in person now has a lot more
steps first a temperature check then a
pump of hand sanitizer before the
plastic gloves come on there are a lot
of candidates running and at early
voting stations when it comes to ID
checks fingerprint scanners have been
replaced with the stylus and a tablet
I'm wearing a mask because everyone else
is wearing and other precautions that
officials here are taking include social
distancing voters are being asked to
stay on one meter apart and the
government even set up early voting
stations at treatment facilities for
covin 19 patients South Korea was able
to go ahead with its election in part
because the country has been taking a
different approach to containing the
virus compared to most Western countries
the government is using an ambitious
strategy of stringent testing contact
tracing and isolation which earned
praise from the w-h-o South Korea
initially emerged as the second worst
hit nation after China but after two
months it has successfully flattened the
curve the country is also not under any
sort of strict nationwide lockdown
because most people here have been
complying with social distancing
guidelines masks were also common before
the pandemic hit all this has helped
keep campaigning close and personal with
some minor adjustments gloves face masks
and microphone slipcovers are essential
for every campaign team one candidate
eager to introduce himself to voters
ditch the face mask for a transparent
shield
I think mask is the my Botha's cannot
Lotus to fool you as the fear of
coronavirus gradually subsides with
fewer new infections Koreans have become
more relaxed about safety precautions
on the campaign trail people flipped
down their face masks for cheek-to-cheek
selfies one voter even unwrapped candy
with her bare hands and popped it into
the mouth of a candidate Korean health
authorities continue to warn that
quickly returning to normal life could
spark a new outbreak but if this vote
runs without causing a subsequent spike
in infections and may provide a roadmap
for other countries with elections
during this unprecedented year of the
pandemic